Por alguna extraña razón que no alcanzo a imaginar,
algo sobre porristas llegó a mi buzón.
Leí esta historia de porristas y es una historia fascinante.
Pasó hace un par de años en EE.UU.
Era una secundaria en EE.UU. donde unas porristas de un equipo
dijeron cosas mezquinas de su entrenadora,
estoy seguro que los muchachos hacen lo mismo con todos su profesores
todo el tiempo,
y de alguna manera la entrenadora se enteró de aquello.
Se disgustó mucho.
Y fue donde una de las chicas, y le dijo,
"tienes que darme tu clave de Facebook".
Leo lo mismo todo el tiempo,
universidades e instituciones educativas donde incluso son forzados a entregar
sus claves de Facebook.
Me tienes que dar tu clave de Facebook.
¡Era una niña!
Lo que debería haber dicho es,
"mi abogado la llamará a primera hora de la mañana.
Es un escandalosa vulneración del derecho a privacidad
establecido en la 4ta enmienda, y la voy a demandar por todo lo que tiene.
Eso debería haber dicho
Pero es solo una niña, y entrega su clave.
La profesora no puede ingresar,
porque la escuela bloqueó el acceso a Facebook.
Tiene que esperar a llegar a la casa para entrar.
La niña le cuenta a las amigas, y adivinen ¿qué pasa?
Entonces, todas entraron a Facebook desde sus teléfono
y borraron su perfiles.
Y cuando la profesora pudo ingresar, no había nada allí.
Mi punto es que ellos no piensan las identidades de la misma forma.
La identidad es algo fluido, especialmente cuando se es adolescente.
Se tiene cantidades, se experimenta con diferentes--
Ud. puede tener una identidad,
y no le gustó porque se la violaron de alguna manera,
o es insegura o inapropiada,
la borra y se hace a otra.
La idea de que se tiene una identidad que le es dada a uno por alguien más,
el gobierno o quien sea,
con la que hay que casarse y usar en todas partes,
es absolutamente errada.
Por otro lado, ¿Por qué querria uno saber quien está en Facebook
si no es para abusar de ellos y acosarlos de alguna forma?
Es un problema complicado.
Y mi cuarto ejemplo es que hay casos en los que uno en verdad quiere ser--
En caso de que se lo estén preguntando,
ese soy yo en la protesta ante la cumbre del G20.
No estaba realmente en la protesta,
pero tenía una reunión en un banco el día de la protesta
y recibí un correo del banco pidiéndome no usar traje
porque eso alteraría a los protestantes.
Francamente, me veo muy bien de traje,
y eso explica lo del frenesí entre ellos.
(Risas)
Y entonces pensé,
si no quieres que enardezcan,
lo más inteligente es ir vestido de protestante.
Y me vestí todo de negro, ya saben, con un pasamontañas negro,
tenía guantes negros que me quité para firmar el libro de visitantes.
(Risas)
Tengo pantalones negros, botas negras,
estoy vestido todo de negro.
Llego puntual y digo, "Hola, soy Dave Birch,
tengo cita con fulano de tal".
Seguro. Me registran.
Me dan mi distintivo de visitante.
(Risas)
No tiene sentido tener nombres reales en Facebook o lo que sea,
que nos den ese tipo de seguridad.
Es un teatro de la seguridad donde no hay seguridad real,
y donde la gente representa su papel en una obra sobre la seguridad.
Y mientras todos sepan sus líneas, todos contentos.
Pero no es seguridad real.
Especialmente porque odio los bancos más que los protestantes del G20,
porque trabajo para ellos.
Se que las cosas son incluso peores de los que ellos piensan.
(Risas)
Pero supongamos que trabajaba en el banco junto a alguien que estaba haciendo algo--
Son como---
Los que toman la plata de los bancos y no-- ¡intermediarios!
Supongamos que estaba sentado junto a un intermediario deshonesto,
y quiero reportarlo al jefe del banco.
Me conecto para delatarlo.
Envío un mensaje, "este tipo es un deshonesto".
Ese mensaje no significa nada si no saben que soy empleado del banco.
Si el mensaje proviene de un NN, tiene cero valor de información.
No tiene objeto mandar ese mensaje.
Ud. tiene que saber que yo soy--
Pero si tengo que identificarme, nunca mandaré ese mensaje.
Como la enfermera del hospital que reporta al cirujano borracho.
Ese mensaje solo se dará si me mantengo en el anonimato.
El sistema tiene que tener formas de garantizar el anonimato en esos casos,
de otra forma no llegaremos donde queremos llegar.
Cuatro casos.
¿Que vamos a hacer al respecto?
Lo que solemos hacer es que pensamos en un espacio orwelliano.
Tratamos de hacer versiones electrónicas del Documento de Identidad
de la que nos deshicimos en 1953.
Creemos que si tuviéramos una tarjeta, llámese nombre de usuario Facebook,
que pruebe quien es Ud, y hacemos que se lleve todo el tiempo,
eso resuelve el problema.
Y por las razones que he esbozado,
no lo hará, y puede en realidad, empeorar algunos problemas.
Cuanto más forzado se vea Ud. a usar su identidad real,
para efectos transaccionales por supuesto,
más propenso estará Ud. a que se la roben y suplanten.
La meta es hacer que la gente deje de usar su identidad en transacciones
que no necesitan la identidad, que son en verdad casí todas.
Casi todas las transacciones que Ud. hace no son, ¿quién es Ud.?
Son, ¿tiene permiso para conducir carro? ¿tiene permiso para ingresar?
¿tiene Ud. más de 18? etcétera, etcétera.
Sugiero--
Yo, como James, creo que debería haber más interés en robo de identidad
Creo que el problema se puede resolver
Hay algo que podemos hacer.
Como es natural, en estas circunstancias yo volteo hacia el Doctor Who.
Porque en esta, como en tantas otras cosas de la vida,
el Doctor Who ya nos ha enseñado la respuesta.
Yo debería decir, para nuestros visitantes foráneos,
que el Doctor Who es el científico Británico vivo más grande,
(Risas)
y un modelo de verdad y esclarecimiento para todos nosotros.
Y aquí está el Doctor Who con su papel psíquico.
Vamos muchachos, deben haber visto el papel psíquico del Doctor Who.
No son nerds porque digan que sí.
¿Quién ha visto el papel psíquico del Doctor Who?
¡Ah, ya! Estuvieron todo el tiempo estudiando, me imagino.
¿Eso es lo que nos van a decir?
El papel psíquico del Doctor Who es ese que cuando uno lo muestra,
la persona, en su cerebro, ve lo que uno quiere que vea.
Quiero mostrarle un pasaporte Británico,
le enseño el papel psíquico y mira un pasaporte Británico.
Quiero entrar a la fiesta,
le enseño el papel psíquico y Ud. ve una invitación a la fiesta.
Ud. ve lo que quiere ver.
Lo que digo es que necesitamos hacer una versión electrónica de eso,
pero con un pequeñísimo cambio,
que es que sólo mostrará el pasaporte si Ud. en realidad tiene uno.
Mostrará que tengo más de 18 si realmente los tengo.
Pero nada más.
Ud. es el portero en el bar, necesita saber si tengo más de 18,
en lugar de enseñarle mi licencia, que le muestra que sé conducir.
cuál es mi nombre, mi domicilio, todo ese tipo de cosas,
le enseño mi papel psíquico, y lo que le dice es si tengo 18 o no.
Bien.
¿Es este un sueño imposible?
Claro que no, sino no estaría aquí hablándoles.
Para crear esto y hacerlo funcionar,
voy a nombrar esas cosas, no voy a ahondar en ellas,
necesitamos un plan,
que es que vamos a crear esto como una infraestructura que todos usarán
para resolver todos estos problemas.
Vamos a hacer un dispositivo, un dispositivo que tiene que ser universal
que se use en todas partes,
voy a ideas de tecnología a medida que avancemos.
Este es un cajero electrónico japonés,
toma la huella guardada en el teléfono móvil.
Cuando Ud. quiere sacar plata, pone el teléfono en el cajero,
toca con el dedo, el teléfono lee su huella digital,
el teléfono dice, "sí, es el que es", y el cajero te da el dinero.
Tiene que ser un dispositivo que Ud. pueda usar en todas partes.
Tiene que ser absolutamente conveniente.
Ese soy yo entrando en el bar.
Todo lo que va a decir el dispositivo en la puerta del bar es,
si esta persona tiene más de 18 y si no tiene ingreso prohibido.
Y entonces la idea es que Ud. arrima la tarjeta a la puerta,
y si puedo entrar, muestro mi foto,
si no, muestra una cruz roja.
No revela ninguna otra información.
No tiene que ser complejo
Esto solo puede significar una cosa, siguiendo la sentencia de Ross
con la que estoy totalmente de acuerdo.
Si no son aparatos especiales, tiene que ser un celular.
Es la única opción: tenemos que usar los celulares.
Hay 6 600 millones de cuentas de celulares
Mi estadística favorita de todos los tiempos,
hay sólo 4 000 millones de cepillos de diente en el mundo.
Eso debe significar algo No se qué
(Risas)
Confío en que los futurólogos me lo digan.
Tiene que ser un dispositivo que sea extensible.
Tiene que ser algo que cualquiera puede usar.
Cualquiera debe poder usar esta infraestructura
sin pedir permisos, licencias, lo que fuera,
todos deberían poder escribir el código para hacer esto.
Todos saben lo que es la simetría, no necesitan un dibujo de eso.
Así es como lo vamos a hacer.
Vamos a usar los celulares
usando la proximidad móvil.
Voy a sugerir que la tecnología
para implementar el papel psíquico del Doctor Who ya está aquí,
y si alguno tiene una nueva tarjeta de débito Barclay
con la interfaz en ella,
ya tiene esa tecnología.
Si alguna vez ha ido al Gran Londres y ha usado la tarjeta Oyster,
¿eso no le suena a algo?
La tecnología ya existe.
Los primeros celulares que tienen la tecnología,
el Google Nexus, el S2, el Samsung Wifi 7.9,
Los primeros teléfonos que tienen esta tecnología
están ya en las tiendas.
La idea es que el hombre del gas pueda aparecer en casa de mi madre
y pueda mostrarle el teléfono, y que ella pueda acercar el de ella
y que aparezca una luz verde si realmente es de la British Gas
y puede entrar,
y aparezca una luz roja si no lo es, fin de la historia.
Tenemos la tecnología para hacerlo.
Y más,
algunas de estas cosas suenan contraintuitivas
¿cómo probar que se tiene 18 sin probar quien soy?,
la criptografía para hacerlo no solo existe,
es muy conocida y bien comprendida.
Las firmas digitales, el cifrado de los certificados de clave pública,
tenemos estas tecnologías hace rato,
es solo que no teníamos forma de empaquetarlas.
La tecnología ya existe.
Sabemos que funciona.
Algunos ejemplos de que la tecnología está siendo usada
de manera experimental en algunos lugares.
Para la Semana de la Moda de Londres, construimos un sistema con O2,
para el Wireless Festival en Hyde Park,
se puede ver las personas caminando con su banda de VIP,
la verificación se hace con el Nokia que lee la banda.
Lo muestro para que vean que estas cosas son prosaicas,
funcionan en estos ambientes.
No necesitan ser especiales.
Finalmente, yo sé que Ud. puede hacer esto,
porque si Ud. vio aquel episodio, el especial de pascuas del Doctor Who,
donde iba a Marte en bus,
debería aclarar para los extranjeros
que no pasa en todo episodio.
Este fue un caso muy especial.
En el episodio en el que va a Marte en bus,
no les puedo mostrar el clip
debido a las vergonzosas restricciones de los derechos de autor,
estilo Reina Ana, de la BBC,
pero en el episodio en que va a Marte en un bus de Londres,
al Doctor Who se lo ve con toda claridad subir a un bus
que tiene un lector de tarjetas Oyster usando su papel psíquico.
Probando así que el papel psíquico tiene una interfaz MSE.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplauso)